patrick forestier écrivain spécialiste
du moyen-orient hauteur de l'hôtel
palestine chronique inattendue de la
guerre en irak aux éditions grasset
bonsoir patrick forestier merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
gouvernement iranien qui nie un
aujourd'hui avoir tenté de masquer la
responsabilité de l'iran dans ce drame
dans ce crash de l'avion ça vous paraît
crédible
les faits parlent d'eux mêmes c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu 48 heures où il ya eu
un flottement à la tête du pouvoir
iranien où les déclarations étaient
contradictoires
les responsables étaient gênés il ya
même eu des déclarations assez
péremptoire du du directeur de
l'aviation civile qui disait que c'était
pas que c'était impossible que missiles
soient tirées donc voilà quarante huit
heures après le pouvoir a dit la vérité
c'était il n'avait pas le choix c'était
le mieux tu dois n'y avait à faire
parce que tout le monde à l'étranger et
à l'intérieur du pays avait compris que
c'était un missile iranien qui avait
donc toucher l'avion
l'ukrainien finalement qu'est-ce qui
reproche le plus les manifestants à leur
gouvernement d'avoir caché la vérité
d'avoir commis cet horrible erreur c'est
quoi le vrai problème est là le vrai
problème je crois que d'abord c'est vrai
que le mensonge je ne passe pas aux
sociétés tout manière d'internet de
communication voilà qui existait
également a évidemment en iran où les
jeunes sont connectés sur internet
donc ça ça ne passe pas du tout et
d'autant plus que les
57 donc iranien qui est qu'ils sont
morts dans cet accident sont des jeunes
soient des jeunes étudiants qui allait
donc étudié à au canada donc si vous
voulez dans les universités et des
familles évidemment les copains sont
très concernés par cet accident et sont
donc très remonté contre le pouvoir qui
est un problème quand même avec la
jeunesse
donc si vous voulez tout se mélange et
c'est quand même une situation difficile
pour le régime iranien aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'il faut le dire l'iran il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes en iran
est un pays où la moyenne d'âge et est
peu élevé est ce que ça peut être un
tournant pour justement le gouvernement
iranien on avait salué cette en tout cas
hills avait salué l'unité retrouvée
après la mort du général souleymane sy
une unité qui à nouveau fragilisée ça
peut représenter un tournant
oui je pense parce que il y a eu
peut-être unité derrière les obsèques du
général sur les manies mais c'était pas
du tout les mêmes le profil si vous
voulez mais bon c'était le voyez sur les
images il y avait des jeunes évidemment
parce qu'ils étaient extrêmement
nombreux mais c'était quand même pas des
étudiants ou des dés
des jeunes qui se passe je vais dire
engagé politiquement
là on a des jeunes qui sont voilà qui
veulent vivre comme le reste de la
planète
ils veulent internet et les filles ont
un problème avec avec le voile
voilà ce sont des choses que l'on
connaît soit des plus des phénomènes de
société
ils sont tous patriotes ils aiment leur
pays et l'iran
il n'y a pas de problème là-dessus mais
ils veulent accéder à ce que tous les
jeunes de la planète accède dire société
de consommation et là ça se recouvrent
si vous lisez ce il ya les deux
problématiques qui s'entrechoquent et ça
ça peut être assez explosif
justement c'était ma prochaine question
est ce que cette dramatique un accident
peut mettre justement le feu aux poudres
à une révolte plus profonde et très
délicate parce que on a les jeunes
étudiants dans les universités qui sont
déjà dans la rue et ce ne soit pas les
parents les familles qui vont les qui
vont aller contre leur enfant si vous
voulez donc c'est sur des problématiques
délicate et on voit on a vu aujourd'hui
pas simple le chef de la police de
téhéran qui a affirmé que le don qu'ils
avaient reçu des ordres à ses strictes
pour ne pas
agir contre manifestation de manière
violente bien on a vu aussi des vidéos
où il eu des tirs déjà sur son
gouvernement allemand d'ailleurs aussi
un qui demande que ces manifestations se
déroulent sans entrave est ce qu'on peut
les craindre justement cette escalade
cette répression on peut le craindre
oui on peut la crainte de 6,6 arrive
plus en avant on a vu comment novembre
il ya eu un black out total de l'iran
qui a qui avait fermé internet et qui
s'était replié sur lui même et qu'il ya
une répression assez sanglante avec
plusieurs centaines de morts là depuis
il y avait les obsèques de ses manies
cavée mais quand même
l'esprit c'était que se souder autour
d'eux autour de cet homme qui était
présenté comme comme étant un grand
serviteur de l'iran mais là je me dis
c'est au nez d'un on est hors politique
sur les sa part de sa part de l'accident
donc c'est pas politique mais quand même
commis par un parent par des gardiens de
la révolution qui sont pas forcément
très aimé par les jeunes
alors est-ce que ce coup du sort c'est
je puis m'exprimer ainsi ne va pas
finalement servir les affaires de donald
trump qui pourtant était sorti
unilatéralement de l'accord qui a voilà
fait éliminer ce général symbolique 1 en
iran et finalement voilà
ce retournement de situation qui le
favorise
bah oui c'est du pain béni pour lui
c'est c'est formidable pour lui là il ne
fait que regarder la télévision et est
envoyé quelques tweets
évidemment et ça suffit d'ailleurs elle
est séduite sera assez modérée 1
ils demandent l apaisement il y dit que
le peuple iranien est un lui sert
d'exemple
voilà donc il demande au régime de ne
pas donc en gros tiré dans la foule
c'est ce qu'il a dit récemment laissé
entendre
donc pour lui rien faire dans cette
affaire dans cette histoire
l'erreur vient de l'iran qui a donc tiré
sur une audience civile une faute
grossière quand même pour une armée qui
se présentait comme comme comme étant à
la pointe du progrès en ce qui concerne
la balistique
donc on peut s'interroger sur sur deux à
partir de ce moment là sur sur les
capacités iraniennes à à bien maîtriser
ces missiles et donc voilà donc si tu
peux me dis je le répète pour prendre le
trump
merci beaucoup patrick forestier d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rd france